what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel like the video on your
way in let's get started so today I am
going to be covering the most crazy
story that I have seen on Twitter in a
while so as you guys know there is a
large percentage of women dating a small
percentage of men basically 80% of women
are dating chasing going after 20% of
men and so the things that these women
do for the 20% of men or put up with or
accept in order to be and compete for
that 20% of men is actually crazy so now
and then you have women or a woman's
friend or someone tells a story that is
brutally honest about something that
happened to them so this was a story
about a woman complaining about an ex
pro hockey player um that was dating her
friend let's pull it
up put a finger down if you ever been
together with a man for eight years and
this man is the love of your life and
he's also a professional hockey player
and so one day he gets a contract to go
play hockey in Russia and it's for an
insane amount of money so we can't turn
it down and because you're supportive
you say yes bab go go to Russia play in
Russia so he does and he's things are
going so well he's playing Amazing you
guys are talking every day you're
talking about rings and weddings because
mind you you've been together for eight
years and he says I can't wait to see
you at the end of February when I come
home and finally the end of February
rolls around and all of a sudden he
disappears he just disappears and you're
freaking out naturally you're saying are
you dead are you in the goog what's
going on and you text his parents and
you text his friends and you say what
happened is he okay and they say what do
you mean he's just on vacation he didn't
tell you so you text him you say what
the [__] you're on vacation what
happened and finally you get a response
back and it says I'm sorry I'm not home
yet I will be home soon this is not a
good response or a drunk response I will
text you a good response
tomorrow and that is the last thing that
you ever hear from him this man you were
together with for eight years this is
the last thing you ever hear from him
and you know that he's alive and he's
fine because he comes home and you see
photos of him home and you text him and
you say can we please talk no response
you box up all of his belongings that
you've accumulated over the past eight
years and you write him a letter saying
can I please get some closure you send
it off no response eventually he goes
back to Russia for the second season and
when he's there about a month in he
posts a photo with a girl and he doesn't
tag the girl and you don't know anything
about the girl but you happen to have
three best friends who are FBI agents
and these girls go in and they figure
out everything about this girl they
figure out who she is they figure out
what she does and they figure out the
timeline of their relationship and they
realize that he and I he and this girl
had been together for quite some time
they've been together for a long time
actually in fact so long that they were
together when he was still talking to
you and saying we're going to get
married and so now you know there was
philandering philandering was
done and the last thing I'll say is put
a finger down if today November 3rd
2023 this man posts a photo of this
woman with a ring on her
hand this is a true story it did not
happen to me it happened to my best
friend of 20 years a woman I have known
for 20 years this is not a novel this
really
happened and Sir if you're watching you
know who you are and you can rot in hell
American women cannot compete with
Russian women I'll tell you that was my
first thought I bet that chick was
Russian or European they're actually
raised much more to be wives there that
is the biggest L I have ever heard of in
my life I cannot imagine being with
someone for eight years and getting
ghosted um so I have a couple questions
in this story were they dating or was it
a situationship because I've noticed
that a lot of these chicks will they'll
think it's a relationship but a lot of
times it's a situationship and this this
chick is going to be undatable after
this can you imagine following a pro
hockey player that ghosted a girl dosted
to the point they're still it's been
like a year and a half after that
they're still checking in on what he's
doing wow that's Big
L so just to be clear these people
committed a federal crime over
this yeah this is like one of the
biggest L's I have ever heard in my life
you know sometimes ladies you just got
to take that L and move on um go to the
next one yeah dude went up Russian and
figured out Western women are broken and
chose a more traditional feminine woman
he made a good choice probably usually
if you have four friends that are FBI
agents D that was the other thing I
noticed they typically just kind of
metal in your relationship typically
women don't typically want other women
to be
happy the second I heard Russia I knew
he massively upgraded the way American
culture has gone I don't blame him a bit
yeah that was my thought I was like a
Russian woman you are not going to win
you are not going to win this girl was
probably the best girl in his hometown
and then he went to Russia and just
thought oh wow wow this is what I can
get for my money and my
looks these we can't compete guys I
don't know what to tell you like the
Russian women have been raised to be
wives the American women are overweight
the Russian women are much more
attractive typically like sometimes it's
kind of like all right all right let me
let me give you guys an analogy
it's like a wreck League playing against
LeBron James does the wreck League think
they're going to win when he went to
Russia I just say goodbye because what
are you going to compete with these
Russian chicks who've been taught from a
young age to serve their men who've been
in shape they're beautiful good luck
good luck she you might as well just
have broken up when he went to Russia
because I could I could have told you
that that was when it was over Big L Big
L you know what's a bigger L the fact
that geopolitical tensions are
escalating inflation is Raging and
despite what they say stocks are sinking
debt is rising in your own financial
future isn't looking too clever yet gold
endures every crisis war and disaster no
Calamity has beat gold while paper
assets crash and burn gold endures every
time you need to take a fresh look at
gold studying your portfolio get a free
5 ounce America the Beautiful coin when
you open up an IRA with Noble gold
Investments today Shield your savings
with Noble gold Investments go to no
gold investments.com noblegold
investments.com that is the only gold
company that I trust I kept scrolling on
Twitter so obviously this woman took an
L ladies uh you know in times past we
used to take the L's and not tell
everybody about it now I know I've been
there we've all been there right taking
a big L but we used to just not go on
Tik talkk not go on Twitter not go about
all these things and you take the L
silently and just move on
move on with your life but nowadays it's
it's really not that it becomes a whole
sob story every woman wants to be like
the star of some movie where the men are
just so mean and evil and really it was
the fact that she went for a hockey
player when really there's like 80% of
men that you could go for that won't do
that to you but you know it's highrisk
high reward if you want to go for the
top guy it's like yeah it's a risky
business um but the thing is women don't
really know what it's like to be in a
man's shoes and there's a lot of things
that women are not willing to do in 2023
you know women demand I want to be equal
to men but don't want the price of
equality that comes with it for example
in relationship you know women want men
to take up all the responsibility they
want them to pay for dates plan them do
everything but they won't give them any
Authority in terms of oh you can't tell
me what to wear you can't tell me what
to do but another aspect that women
don't want to do in society is women
want to be equally respected in society
for the work that they do but women do
not want to do equal work so there's a
video I saw on Twitter of a job that
really is looking for female applicants
they said ladies please apply here we
need diversity and inclusion so please
apply let's pull it
up
[Music]
Ava Ava they're
applying I have it for you apply to
these jobs they are willing and taking
applicants and they just they really
want you to come forward and do these
jobs diversity and inclusion all the
women in HR that demand to be taken
seriously please apply for these hard
jobs all these women that just say
they're they're taking on the the City
by storm and just really tearing down
this patriarchy I have the job for you
please apply here and this is the
problem guys women will never do those
jobs never women will never be the
majority of mechanics truckers or any of
the hard jobs in society and when they
do apply for these jobs and do these
jobs you know what I get from a lot of
these guys that these women just mess
everything up and then they give them
the easiest parts of the job and then it
makes the other guy's jobs harder
because women are always doing less work
feminists apply please apply here the
comment section weighs in on this and
says I wonder why women don't want to
work jobs like this I don't know
Isabella I don't know I'm look it I
please apply here all of you women that
demand equal pay I have the job for you
I hear it pays really well and you will
be well respected and loved by all
G dub says they want to be equal but not
that equal yes because women do not want
to do the hardest jobs in society they
do not want to actually be equal they
want special privileges and freedoms
without the responsibility that comes
with it women live life on easy mode
they have all the easy jobs in society
they get special treatment and they
don't do the work and until women start
doing the work I'm not going to feel bad
for you when you're complaining about
your student debt you know we have all
these women coming out complaining about
all the debt they have yet they order
new clothes every week they go out to
eat every week and they go traveling and
you question how do you afford this so
many of them are living on credit card
after credit card after credit card they
have a boatload of debt and the
government and Men keep having to bail
them out I mean all look at look at what
has happened with all this student loan
debt who who has the majority of student
don't loan debt who has the majority of
student loan debt women women ladies
it's time to put the credit cards away I
almost think that men should take away
our bank accounts why do you think we
didn't have bank accounts because we
couldn't handle them all we do is swipe
swipe swipe Jeff plink weighs in and
says the first thing I will do as
president is mandate that wine box
tiktock feminists be immediately
transferred from their corporate
managerial careers to the oil fields the
electric line crews in the name of
diversity inclusion and equity and you
know what's funny women basically do
nothing at these corporate jobs now guys
are there women that do make money yeah
obviously obviously before you say oh oh
Pearl but they're smart women um yeah
unicorns exist but that doesn't make
them not unicorns oh my goodness like
for
everyone I worked in Corporate America
for everyone awesome sales
chip there was just like three managers
bitching at everybody and doing
nothing nothing we are tired of the
women that do nothing get rid of Human
Resources get rid of all these diversity
and inclusion programs why is diversity
and inclusion something we are striving
for it should be the best person for the
job so yeah ladies all I want all
diversity and inclusion professionals
put their money where their mouth is and
go out there and do that job and if
you're not willing to do that Poli stop
bitching about your pay because all the
women that go online and cry and moan
and whine about not getting paid enough
are just lazy you heard it here first no
Nothing is Stopping You you actually
have an advantage in most places so
instead of using it you cry on Tik Tok
because you're a fat feminist who's got
nothing better to do modern women will
still complain that this guy making six
figures isn't doing housework or tending
to the kids after work yes yes I there
is a huge debate on Twitter right now
there's a huge debate with my friend
Rachel Wilson where she talked about
that her husband doesn't lift a finger
when he comes home she does all of the
housework and so many
tradcons start crying and complaining
that her husband doesn't do the
housework and that husbands should do
the housework guys what sounds more
pleasant as a wife I'm just I'm just
wondering I'm just wondering now I'm not
saying you can't do the housework right
but what sounds more
pleasant baby you don't have to lift a
finger when you come home or a woman
that's going to whine and nag about not
helping enough I I saw a tweet recently
that said that in marriage you shouldn't
expect your husband to lift a finger
that you should not expect him to help
you with chores at all if he does great
but managing expectations is the key to
a happy relationship but again it goes
back to egalitarianism the men need to
help equally in the home even though
even if they're both working because
that's the other thing I'm so tired of
you people I'm so tired of you people
coming in and saying well these guys
don't make enough money um they're
brokies they're losers they don't make
enough money um well news flag we still
need men to do average jobs in society
not everybody can make a ton of money
and the reason that is is because there
are normal roles that are right now are
being subsidized by women I this is what
I truly believe I truly believe that
women have come into the work force some
women do why do I keep having to say
some women work we all know but the most
women don't really provide much value
and the men have to pick up their slack
for the stuff they're not doing and you
can shoot the messenger but most women
jobs are useless I'll give you an
example let's talk about female teachers
um women have effectively ruined the
education system they've absolutely
ruined it and what are teachers known
for what what stories are coming out now
all the female teachers sleeping with
their students I see way more stories
like that than I see of the men doing
the exact same thing um women
effectively have no consequences in life
they can do whatever they want they can
divorce and leave their family and still
be known as a Godly woman they can
literally be useless at work and still
get paid a high earning six figure
salary at some of these tech companies
you guys saw them during Co before Co
happened all of these girls were saying
this is what I do in a day oh here's my
latte oh I went into a meeting oh I
played ping pong at work and then you
see them crying six months later because
they got laid off of course of course
you're going to get La off
obviously anyway so I see Tokyo as the
future of the world now I when I say
this I don't mean in terms of modesty
clearly Western women are not going to
pick up modesty and femininity from
Tokyo but what you see in Tokyo is more
5050 relationship so it's far more
common to split the bill there um you
see an increase of sexless
all together and the birth rate has been
on the decline there for a very long
time I see that being the future and I
think in some of these Asian countries
you're going to see women actually
spending money on men and women being
the bread winner I think that's going to
be more Commons there's a woman going
viral who spent 200k on a Tokyo jiggalo
in six months and then he discarded her
this woman stabbed him and I will die on
this hill guys I will die on this hill
women are more violent than men we are
not the more nurturing sex I do not
believe it for a second women get very
angry and emotional and we are far more
willing to commit violent crimes than
men in the right situations the problem
is our fists do not double as a weapon
because most of us are not strong enough
to do that I I think women are far more
violent than men I don't buy this
narrative I think it's feminist
propaganda that women and again you you
you'll start to hear it it's always
women have this special amazing
awesomeness that is just this
specialness of femininity and just
awesome amazingness ah and it's never
something you can measure because when
women get power we're more violent with
it we're more likely to wage war when we
get power we're more likely to kill
infants and the elderly and many times
women actually convince other men to
commit their crimes for them how many
men were killed during the me too
movement because a woman accused a guy
of something let's let's pull up the
video of this woman stabbing the guy
though
let's
fore
[Music]
hold
okay
[Music]
fore
you
gete
for
so I do think this guy survived um I
think he got stabbed with a box cutter
so I do think he survived but a couple
things I wanted to point out he got
stabbed in front of
everybody in front of everybody do you
think if the roles were reverse that
would have happened like imagine if a
guy spent 200 can a woman Which is far
more common than vice versa I mean how
many men I mean you know Andrew Tate ran
that whole cam girl thing right and
there are videos of him talking about
how he would get hundreds of thousands
of dollars out of some of these guys and
what if those men came out and stabbed
the woman in front of everybody do you
think that they would have gotten to do
that so I I caption this that I will die
on the hill that women are more violent
than men um so I heard Jen cavlo say no
men commit violent crimes more than
three times as often as women this is a
fact so couple things what if we
included women
murdering I don't
know call me crazy I don't know they're
children they're kids but it's funny
it's funny they they'll never classify
that as a violent crime one out of three
women have literally murdered their
child
what if we counted plan B's in that
which I know that's disputed but fine
let's just go with the actual abortion
infanticide is actually so rare for men
to do it it's basically unheard of when
women get power they are more violent
the only reason that women do not commit
as many violent crimes as men it is
because they do not have the physical
capacity to do so and I would also argue
the mental capacity you're never going
to get a female Jeffrey dmer the men are
just smart they figure out a better way
to do it and three then they always
conveniently don't count they don't
count the murders of their own children
I would argue that if we started
actually punishing women for abortion
and counting that women would commit far
more violent crimes by and large it
wouldn't even be close it wouldn't even
be close reclaim your throne says of
course they are looking at women
throughout history who've had power Mar
Mary one of England better known as
Bloody Mary Elizabeth I Katherine the
Great all of these women in leadership
roles were brutal in their list for
blood yeah when women get power they're
typically not good with it and I get so
much heat because I'm told I hate women
because I live in reality guys I live in
reality you can't tell me that men are
the more violent people when okay I'm
going to give you an edit this in when
in the early 2000s there was a clip of a
woman joking on national TV about
chopping a man's off because he cheated
and they were joking that that woman
shouldn't be punished imagine if the
roles were reversed and men were joking
about mutilating a woman because she
cheated oh never they would never they
would never but women can do it son of
Aragon says abortion alone makes that
the case yes yes yes
yes women I'll die on this hill women
are far more violent than men nobody can
convince me otherwise I have only I know
you guys are shocked I have only been
scared that I would get attacked by a
woman never really a guy it's always
women that do it and the problem is we
live in this delusional world where we
tell women we're more special and
important than we are all the time
there's marketing and propaganda 247
saying you're so important you were so
special you were so amazing you are so
smart we have an entire school system
dedicated to making us think that we're
smarter than we are and I'm going to
show you a clip that's going to prove my
point so there's a woman that has a
PHD that was asked to take an IQ test
someone with a PhD you would think
that's the highest level of
Education you must be very intelligent
to get that right the school system
doesn't favor women right women are just
very smart productive members of society
when they go get educated let's let's
show the clip I'm 21 I'm a high school
graduate and I work in the Marine Corps
I'm 30 years old I have my PhD in cancer
biology and I work in a Biotech Industry
grad school I went to University of
South Carolina and undergrad I went to
University of Florida 1 2
3 4 5 6 to me I don't know PhD cancer
biology scientist I work in a biotech
company we make coid 19 testing kits
stuff like that and then it has nothing
to do with your background I don't think
you really have the highest EQ out of
all of us Tyler he ranked last for me
personally because the way he carries
himself he was ranking intelligence
based on his point of view and not
taking in other people's point of views
so number one is REM number two would be
Kaye number three would be Tyler and
number four would be Shera number five
is sea and number six is
Maria
[Music]
there you have it folks a woman imagine
a woman thinking she's smarter than she
is why would she think that why you know
what's funny I remember the time in life
I have a little brother I remember the
day in my life when I realized that my
little brother was smarter than me to
this day I'll tell you that um it
was I I remember because my little
brother would always like he's kind of
bossy my little my little brother he's
bossy guy and he would always boss me
around and I didn't want to listen to
him you don't want to listen to your
little brother and I remember one day we
used to fight when I was a kid and one
day I just realized that he was smarter
than me and I started listening to him I
realized he was right about most things
you know that was the day we got along
after that really and truly but now this
woman who's so smart does all this
testing is so amazing so then my
question is how did she make it through
school how does she have this J job if
she's literally the least smart and the
lowest IQ and she's working at this big
Tech or whatever company my guess is
probably a man is doing most of the work
for her yes so Savannah says if there's
one thing I've learned it's usually that
the people who have medical degrees are
some of the dumbest and most ignorant
Among Us imagine spending hundreds of
thousands of dollars not even
questioning whether or not you should
understand basic nutrition and its
relation to the human body then spending
the rest of your life handing approved
big Pharma medication that doesn't
actually heal people yeah I remember
being in high school this kind of a
weird lesson my dad taught me when I was
younger it's funny because when I was a
kid my dad um he he would tell me these
like little bits of wisdom I guess that
didn't make sense to me at the time or I
thought he was just like old or whatever
at the time but then you get older and a
lot of stuff sort of starts to make
sense so an example of this was one time
when I was a kid I was really struggling
in math and like I remember my dad dad
would spend like hours with me trying to
teach me math and he would get so
frustrated CU I just couldn't do it I
was so bad and um I remember it was like
after a game or something that I had he
was driving me home and he says and I
said to him like Dad you don't
understand with the school stuff you
don't get it you're so smart like you
just you would never understand because
my dad excelled really at school from a
young age like he went to the University
of Chicago which is like a really
prestigious University I'm from and I
remember he told me he looked at me and
he said in life you know it's really not
about who's the smartest it's about who
works the hardest because you know if
you work hard for five 10 15 20 30 years
it adds up and over time the people that
are born smart they just can't compete
and he told me that in the second half
of your life you really see who worked
hard and who was just gifted from a
young age um and he also told me CU I
remember I would I wanted to go to Notre
Dame that was was like my dream school
when I was in high school I'm Irish so
it was like Irish Catholic University
and you know I I I would never have
gotten in there so I didn't even apply
but like they wouldn't have taken me and
um my dad I remember he would tell me
that some of the dumbest people he's
ever met in his life have gone to Ivy
League and prestigious universities and
he would tell me that basically that
stuff means nothing it means absolutely
nothing and again I would say well
that's easy for you to say Dad went to
one you're so
smart and I get older and I I realized
how righty was because I I was telling
the story before I did the video one of
the smartest women that I ever knew um
she got like a 34 in her act which is if
you're not from the Midwest that's like
ungodly High that's like nobody gets
that high on their acts she did and she
believed in the men are women and women
are men stuff like a woman that's smart
and it makes you question the whole
education system how are people this
idiotic getting this far in life and in
their careers and I would hypothesize
that many times women go through life
because men are doing the work for them
um and I think it's very similar to the
WNBA where the women think they're doing
so amazing and awesome and really it's
just charity work the men are paying for
everything and instead of having
gratitude for the men they [__] on them
as a thank you J X hippie says the thing
I have learned over the years is that
degrees show nothing more than the
ability to continue to show up to a
class and copy quotes to write a paper
it has nothing to do at all with
intelligence I have been judged all my
life for being dyslexic yet my I my IQ
is
136 I totally agree with that because
the thing is they switched the education
system it used to be just more
standardized tests you have have a test
day every three months or whatever it
was and you're tested on the material
but they made the education system more
feminized um again men operate on a
hierarchy who has the highest IQ women
are more likely to operate more
egalitarian so everybody's special and
amazing and awesome so what did they do
they added
in participation trophies essentially
you show up and you get points just for
showing up to class being on time um
they add in these papers these
assignments all of these little useless
kind of useless things that kind of prop
up your grade a little bit and I totally
benefited from it I look back to being
in school I totally did better on the
written stuff the assignments where both
of my brothers because I I grew up
between two boys both of my brothers
they really accelerated more in the
testing and I think a lot of men view
all of the little stuff as kind of
useless like they they don't see the
point and this is why a lot of parents
are going to home schooling that's why
you see this huge rise in the number of
people that are homeschooled because the
faith in the education system is is
going going downhill jaxel says you can
tell the contempt that they have for
each other she shows her contempt
without restraint because she has been
taught that her feelings are right well
he has contempt for her but he is hiding
it behind a smile because it's not
proper he was brought up right she
wasn't yeah and I think that's true you
know so many times women have really
lost like decency
you know just because you feel a certain
way about someone it doesn't really
matter you're still meant to be polite
you're still meant to smile and be nice
to them and I really hate this new
culture that we have we're saying that's
somehow fake or that they're fake
whatever when really it's just being a
decent and polite human being and we've
sort of lost that in society like
especially when I came to London that
was like a big I'm from the Midwest and
I hated London for the first year I
remember I had like something that I in
the beginning I just started saying hi
to people randomly and people would look
at me like I was crazy they would look
at me like I was insane because it's
just not people just aren't as friendly
here like they are in the Midwest and
really the older I get the less friendly
I see people becoming Maggie Rock says
the full video is hard to watch I
actually feel like the military guy's
definition of intelligence was probably
the most accurate but more than half of
them started laughing when the ones said
I don't place a lot of value on the
military who said they don't place a lot
of value on the
military like
[__] and again you know this is why I
get older and I start to realize the
things that my dad said were right
there's a lot of people that act like
they're smarter than they are and it's
funny one Telltale sign that I can tell
that someone isn't as smart as they are
is that they're always talking about how
smart they are because if you're really
that smart you you don't even have to
tell anybody that you just people can
just get gather that from you like the
smartest people like you never see
Jordan Peterson saying oh I am so smart
and amazing and awesome you just hear
him talk and you realize he's a really
knowledgeable guy and speaking of things
that are downplayed in society and in
the media dark clouds are gathering
markets shutter stocks are sinking
currencies stumbling fear and
uncertainty rain in the Middle East
Ukraine Taiwan the debt it is endless
but one asset stands firm gold in crisis
after crisis gold is there in the
background it's enduring value guards
against LW like a missile Shield against
the incoming while paper wealth Burns
gold persist Shield your savings against
looming threats for recession contagion
and avoid the frenzied Panic of the
unprepared take control and Chaos
fortune favors decisive action get a
hold of gold now before it's Out Of
Reach right now Noble gold Investments
offers a free 5 ounce America the
Beautiful coin with every new Ira claim
your free coin today to secure your
financial future as these storms get
gather Panic looms and some of the
places you were thinking of your money
well they don't look so clear anymore
secure your future against disaster
opening Noble gold Investments IRA and
claim your free coin today go to
noblegold investments.com that's
noblegold investments.com the only gold
company that I trust so our last story
today women ruin
everything women ruin everything really
we've ruined the workforce with me too
we even ruined women's sports by whining
and complaining about pay and now we're
ruining gyms yes ruining gyms there was
a woman that decided to make a skit of
how women are just ruining the gym let's
pull it up hi guys this is a tutorial on
how to make a guy look like a creep at
the gym first I like to set up the
barbell in the free weight area directly
in front of my Victim wearing tiny
shorts then I start doing rdl's for him
to see that [__] fat and grab his
attention I'll then stop my workout turn
around and confront him about perving on
me making sure I'm getting all of this
on camera next I'll green screen my my
video and talk about how I feel violated
and then post on my social media so I
reive comments from other girls saying
go sis see you next time and so she's
making fun of this but she's right she's
right these women look it h they're half
naked in the
gym and they get mad when the men look
imagine okay imagine if I was dressed up
as a police officer and I got mad when
people came up to me and said why are
you dressed like a police offic or sir
or sorry ma'am or ma'am ma'am please
help me I need help whatever it's like
well what did you expect dressed like
that the comments in the video really
are supporting this chick Walt says even
an old guy like me sees it at almost
every session in the gym now I never saw
it 10 to 15 years ago yeah it used to be
like weird to bring a camera even even
just five years ago I'm thinking nobody
really recorded their workouts like that
but now the cameras are coming in and I
was just about to say this segregated
gyms they can be as naked as they like
and men can work out in
peace yes I I think you're gonna I we
should start a male only gym because
really and truly it's like if you're GNA
keep coming to the gym half naked and
then getting mad when men look it's like
men can't win they're like okay I'm here
to work out I'm going to get my gym on
and then boom all the women come in and
they're like oh look at that they're
half nak nak it then the women are like
why are you looking at me it's kind of
weird to think about because growing up
in my generation yoga pants are so
normal like it's so normal you know I
mean we had spandex from a super young
age like you're 12 and you're given
spandex as part of your uniform for
volleyball and it's kind of weird to
think about like how immodest and not
normal that is for the older generation
like yoga pants leggings I'll hear
people over the age maybe 40 talk about
it and they can't believe that this is
just normal for people to wear and I
remember being 18 I was in Germany um
because I grew up with nannies from
Germany so when I was 18 I went to
Germany and I lived with one for the
summer and I remember I had a couple
pairs of leggings and it was like what
they looked at they were like what are
you wearing but it's super normal in the
US so it kind of begs the question of
like what is appropriate to wear in the
gym now it's just ridiculous it's like
women in scores sprws and like boot like
it's just crazy you know it was kind of
like baggy t-shirts when I was in high
school you know it begs the question if
you're going to come to the gym half
naked can you really be mad if men look
there was another woman that I saw on
Twitter I think it's from a Tik Tok
account but on Twitter talking about how
she doesn't know what to do this woman
is so confused what does she do after
the gym she goes to the gym half naked
and then after she doesn't know what to
do let's pull it up it says wearing a
cute gym set is also fun and games until
you look like a complete [__] after at
the grocery
store are women this
stupid are we really this
dumb okay because all right again I'm a
volleyball player you wear Spandex and
volleyball but everybody brings pants to
wear after I have such a simple
solution I have two solutions and I just
I I want to know if this is like real
okay but I'm I'm gonna be nice I'm gonna
be
nice all right option one you could wear
something else to the gym
ah I
know I know this is crazy no no but she
can't do that that's too she has her
matching gy set okay option
two the same way when you wear a
swimsuit to the beach you bring a cover
up you could you could wear sweats after
anyways just my two cents I guess
don't shoot the messenger um Elijah
schaer says female gym clothes are just
underwear oh
yeah oh yeah I'm a gym regular and I'm
waiting for the day they just start
working out in the nude not complaining
just noticing how the amount of clothing
worn seems to be getting less and less
yeah women go into any space that we
just get naked it's getting really
ridiculous like we go into they're
starting to get naked in church it's
like the audacity can you imagine an and
women fight for the oh my gosh
mothers will fight for the ability to be
naked they they'll get naked in front of
their children and then take pictures
and post it on the
internet women are like please please
please let me be naked oh please I need
to be
naked like what is wrong with you
people a secure person has their own
standards but never imposes upon others
maybe she should be more modest and not
surprised men tend to have have distaste
maybe others should simply have better
dignity and decency is isn't it isn't
that obscene it goes both ways I mean
you know what you know what's so
interesting as a chick I find it
distracting when these chicks are half
naked like I find it distracting it's
like I'm I'm trying to work out I find
it distracting I can't imagine what the
men think you know what I mean like it's
got to be so distracting with these
chicks just throwing their bodies in
their face and you know what else is sad
There are men that want to be faithful
to their girlfriend friends and their
wives and they can't go anywhere without
all these women throwing their nakedness
please please look at me naked it's
like anyway so you know now women have
also ruined the gym um thank you guys
for watching this episode make sure you
get yourself a women shouldn't vote
t-shirt on your way out um that's at the
audacity network. store that's the
audacity network. store and lastly guys
as you guys know every episode we read
the top comment from the previous video
so make sure you go vote below by liking
your favorite comment and leave a
comment below mostly peaceful Matthew
says most modern women who have high
body couns are very little know deep
down that saying you're a virgin is
still considered valuable they know deep
down that they promiscuous past is not
what men want thank you mostly peaceful
Matthew for your comment thank you guys
for watching get yourself a women [__]
and vote t-shirt like the video on your
way out and we'll talk to you next time